what Khan Academy is today could best be
described as a tool or a resource it's
right now if you go to the site we have
videos we have interactive exercises we
have dashboards for teachers and so
depending it could be used as a teacher
to help their students it could be used
by a home schooler who wants to learn
something independently it could be used
for an adult who wants to review things
that might be relevant to whatever
they're they're exploring at the moment
but one thing I'd like to be clear is we
don't view this as the end-all of of
what we think one this could be and even
how students should experience learning
we think that this is really just
version one and it's a very primitive
version right now of a tool that will
eventually empower a true interactive
vision of Education and the other thing
I want to make very clear is we don't
see it as an either/or proposition we
don't see it as a virtual versus
physical eh-eh amazon.com versus Barnes
and Noble's we see it as a virtual and
physical or even better how do we use
the tools and resources of the virtual
how do we use those to actually empower
the physical to make the physical the
best the best possible experience and in
this vision of what the total education
experience can be we have a couple of
core philosophies the first is the idea
of mastery learning mastery learning and
I'll write it in quotes because mastery
can mean different things to different
people to us this is the general idea
that students should have deep
conceptual understanding of core ideas
of more fundamental ideas before they
are pushed ahead to the more derivative
ideas or the more advanced ideas and so
if you think of a traditional
progression in mathematics although we
would think of the supplies beyond just
mathematics traditional progression of
mathematics you start off with
arithmetic and then you go to and then
you go to algebra and then you go
through trigonometry and geometry and
all the rest but you eventually end up
in you eventually end up in
calculus and what we believe is
happening for too many students and this
is why so many students end up having
trouble with algebra and definitely
calculus is they are not getting mastery
of the more fundamental ideas we believe
that students have the time to really
build a strong foundation in arithmetic
including exponents in whatever whatever
else then by the time algebra comes
around they will have a better intuition
there they have a better chance of
understanding it and if students have a
conceptual deep understanding of algebra
then calculus is going to make a lot
more sense if you do it the other way
around if you just push students through
so that their you know they get through
with 80% 90% understanding then what
they essentially end up doing just to
survive is start doing a superficial
level of understanding they start kind
of pattern matching their way through
algebra or calculus and not only does
that harm you later on as you keep
building on it it also makes it almost
impossible to use these things in your
everyday life in our minds it's much
more valuable to have a deep
understanding of algebra and being able
to see the world in an algebraic way
then just getting through algebra and
kind of understanding calculus but being
able to apply or really fundamentally
understand neither the other idea and
this kind of gels with mastery based
learning you kind of can't have mastery
based learning at least in our minds
without a kind of self-paced without a
self-paced reality because if we really
want students to master things we really
have to give them the time and the space
to master those concepts if everyone
else has mastered in they're ready to
move on there's no reason why we have to
move them on we should let them work at
their own pace
the other big thing about self-paced
learning is that it creates student
ownership and this is a huge huge huge
thing this is a huge huge huge thing
probably the most important thing that
you can learn while you are learning in
school isn't necessarily any one of
these subject areas figuring out how to
solve a system of equations or take an
integral the most important thing to
learn is how to learn how do you take
ownership of something how do you to
some degree how do you how do you become
your own guide how do you how do you set
your own goals and this can only happen
in a self paced environment
we're with mentorship with people who
can guide you you can say look this is
what I want to learn this is how I want
to go about learning it and this is what
I'm gonna do to get there and my goal is
mastery my goal isn't just to get by the
other thing we believe strongly in and
we're starting some we've been working
with many many schools we've been
working with many schools across all of
this including just how we define our
tools and our resources is the idea of
students teaching students or we could
call it maybe peer-to-peer peer-to-peer
teaching and learning and there's an
obvious benefit there of if if you have
other students around maybe some who
have gotten a little bit further ahead
who can tutor you you have more access
to people who might be able to help you
but we think it's even it's at least as
powerful for this for the student
getting tutored as it is for the student
doing the tutoring because it's one
thing to do a lot of problem sets and to
to kind of go through subjects in the
traditional way but to truly get mastery
of something and I think most teachers
would agree with this you really have to
teach it you really have to be able to
distill it and explain it and help and
help mentor other people to it and on
top of that you'll build other soft
skills where it's which are at least as
important like ownership as these other
kind of tangible skills the skills of
empathy the skills of being able to
listen to someone the skills of kind of
of being able to guide someone without
making them feel intimidated or insecure
and then finally the the fourth guiding
principle for us is the idea that
students students and this is very core
to the physical experience that when
students are together they should be
interacting so it should be interactive
and when we talk about interactive we're
not talking about computer interact
we're talking about physical interactive
they should interact with other human
beings they should talk to them they
should smile they should see them and it
should be inquiry based or exploration
base inquiry exploration and this is
super key to everything we believe and
this is why we are actively
experimenting with summer camps that are
driven all around this part this part of
the experience is because we believe
that in order for a student to truly
internalize all of these things and it
all goes together with especially the
idea of mastery they needed to struggle
with the idea
they need to experience them tangibly
and you know for example we have
students they do things that are
implicitly probability but they don't
know they think they're just doing a
simulation they think that they're just
playing some type of a game but by doing
those simulations in those games later
on when they are exposed to kind of the
more formal academic ideas around
probability or expected value they now
have a tangible understanding for them
they now have an intuitive understanding
for them they now and they also see the
value in the more formal representation
of it so hopefully this gives a big
picture of what we are about we are a
tool and a resource today but the whole
goal is to keep it and we want people to
use it in any way that they see fit that
can be part of a formal program it could
be a supplement it could be used as a
review of somehow but our real goal is
how can we optimize this tool how can we
improve this tool so that we can really
drive these values to make a truly
holistic education experience